Here we can see a time series plot of U.S. civilian unemployment rate over time.
The data goes all the way back to about 1950,
and all the way up until the present time.
On the Y axis we have unemployment percent.
If you notice it tops out at around 11% and the lowest value is around 3%.
Something to always be careful of with your plots is to clearly label and
be aware of what the ranges of your data are.
Both on the Y and on the X.
In this case, since we are plotting a time series,
every point is not completely independent of every other point.
The X variables here depend on one another.
Since the value at time X depends on X minus 1.
In more concrete terms,
the unemployment in 1970 is some delta from the unemployment in 1969.
And the unemployment rate in 1969 is some change from the unemployment rate
in 1968.
Since we're trying to convey how something's changed over time, a line plot is
the most natural and easily understandable of all the chart types.